bonjour je m'appelle loïc fel je suis co
fondateur de l'association chorale qui
est dédiée à la promotion de l'écologie
par la culture et de l influence fargo
d'une agence de plaidoyer et de lobbying
qui travaille essentiellement sur le
pragmatique d'urbanisme et d'écologie il
se trouve que dans mes métiers
l'outil le plus puissant dont je dispose
pour accompagner une certaine emprise
sur les consciences c'est l'art
contemporain comment j'en suis venu à
identifier l'art comme étant un outil
puissant d'accompagnement au changement
comportements collectifs et d' influence
cette histoire commence quand j'étais
petit à petit dans le village où je suis
né qui s'appelle waldighoffen à la
frontière suisse un village du xingù en
alsace un petit village bucolique et
idyllique très champêtre qui pourtant a
été confronté à grease écologique en
1986 cette année a marqué dans la
mémoire collective une prise de
conscience écologique à cause de la
catastrophe de tchernobyl en avril
mais l'histoire qui m'a marquée elle a
émergé le 1er novembre 1986 c'est une
usine pharmaceutique s'appelle
schweizerhalle et en suisse qui a
explosé avec la même réaction chimique
que celle à l'origine de l'explosion de
l'usiné azf ou deux par deux liban cet
été et cette usine a déversé un nuage
orange dans les mémoires qui a envahi la
vallée dont celle de mon village et à ce
moment là une voiture passer avec des
haut-parleurs pour indiquer à la
population de bien vouloir remettre des
linge mouillé mouillé au bas de leurs
portes et autour de leur fenêtre pour
empêcher l'air d'entrer à ce moment là
mon univers a complètement changé je me
suis rendu compte qu'il existait un
monde au delà qu'ils pouvaient influer
mon petit espace bucolique et que
l'environnement n'est pas si bien que ça
et d'ailleurs l'environnement même dans
mon village
elle est déjà très mal mais j'en avais
pas conscience à l'époque on a failli
perdre des cigognes qui sont le symbole
de l'alsace
il n'y avait plus que quelques couples
nicheurs sur l'ensemble de notre région
mais un mouvement populaire s'est
engagée et jusqu'à il ya quelques années
a appris aux cigognes à ne plus
effectuer leur migration pour renforcer
la résistance et la population et ce
programme a réussi on a réussi
à démultiplier le nombre de couples
nicheurs et aujourd'hui rien que dans
mon village il ya trois couples nicheurs
pourquoi est ce qu'on a réussi à sauver
la cigogne alors qu'il existe un autre
animal en alsace qui lui est en voie
d'extinction a suivi la même dynamique
et a quasiment disparu à savoir le grand
hamster d'alsace ou autrement appelée la
marmotte de strasbourg en fait la raison
en est simple c'est que ce petit animal
ne fait pas partie de notre identité de
notre iconographie ou de notre art
l'image précédente que je viens de vous
montrer ses les motifs ainsi ces motifs
sont les motifs traditionnels d'un
dessinateur alsacien très connu et qui
se retrouvent sur toute l'iconographie
la carterie la papeterie la vaisselle
donc la cigogne à une place centrale
dans notre imaginaire et dans notre
identité
ce n'est pas le cas du hamster donc
cette différence de mobilisation pour
sauver les cigognes tient uniquement à
une dimension culturelle qui est passé
par la diffusion des images donc l'art
d'être un vecteur extrêmement puissant
pour lutter contre l'érosion de la
biodiversité et le changement climatique
est accompagné des transformations
sociales
il peut le faire de bien des manières et
celle là où ça devient un outil
extrêmement intéressant parce qu'en plus
d'être puissant d'être visible d'avoir
une certaine aura attribué par la
société parce que c'est de l'art mais
aussi une certaine pérennité parce qu'on
va le conserver parce que c'est du
patrimoine
mais son influence va bien au delà et se
démultiplient où se décline de plusieurs
manières
la première des influences qui est
souvent insoupçonnées parce qu'on pense
d'abord à l' influence des images c'est
que l'art c'est aussi une industrie et
c'est pas n'importe quelle industrie
c'est une industrie puissante qui a la
capacité de payer cher certains éléments
parce que la veille m beaucoup
d'exigence et du coup elle est
prescriptif auprès de beaucoup d'autres
industries
l'image que je vous montre par exemple
ici c'est la réserve des arts à paris
qui est en fait une association avec un
entrepôt dédié à la récupération des
matériaux issus des productions
culturelles telles que les théâtres les
opéras les innograd exposition pour
créer une dynamique et d'économie
reculèrent au sein des disciplines
artistiques parce que le scénographie
par exemple on est très exigeants sur
les matériaux on peut demander des
innovations on peut financer de la
recherche développement via des projets
culturels
mais ils ne sont utilisés que le temps
de l'exposition après ça partent à la
poubelle
en réalité à la fois via ses commandes
et via la destination finale de ces
matériaux utilisés dans le cadre de
l'art il est possible en tant
qu'industrie d'avoir une importante
influence et elle a une influence
majeure pour donner juste un chiffre aux
etats unis les industries culturelles en
californie représente le deuxième impact
environnemental de l'état derrière
l'industrie pétrochimique et bien avant
toutes les autres
l'ars a aussi une autre puissance sur
les consciences et un effet extrêmement
extrêmement forts dont on a un peu plus
l'habitude mais qui est particulièrement
important pour la question de l'écologie
c'est celle de la prise de conscience et
de la sensibilisation
l'image que je vous montre ici c'est une
oeuvre de michael jones qui a travaillé
sur la base des informations données par
les rapports officiels du gect du groupe
intergouvernemental intérêts tard
d'étude du climat et qui ici présente
avec un petit cercle bleu le futur
niveau maximal des océans au vu des
scénarios du changement climatique en
fait le changement climatique comme
l'érosion de la biodiversité quelques
autres phénomènes sur ce que le
philosophe américain edward norton
appelle des hypers phénomène c'est à
dire des phénomènes qui sont en dehors
de notre temporalité de vie qui excède
nos capacités de perception et qui
excède les dimensions dont on a
l'habitude ou auxquels on a l'habitude
de réfléchir avec ce simple petit
marqueur bleu subitement le changement
climatique fait irruption dans notre
expérience vécue et notre expérience
quotidienne
subitement il prend une dimension
concrète et ça c'est mobilisateur tant
que le risque reste abstrait comme quand
il y a écrit sur un paquet de cigarettes
fumées tuent sas une information c'est
pas sensibles c'est pas dans notre monde
vécue
connaître un malade là ça devient
concret voir ce marqueur dans notre
espace de vie quotidienne là ça devient
concret et c'est un vecteur de
mobilisation
autre facteur aussi c'est la capacité de
l'art explorer des solutions et à les
promouvoir à l'exemple que je vous
montre ici il s'agit de a crevé un duo
anglais qui a développé une technique de
production d' image écologique en
l'occurrence il s'agit d'un porte du
portrait de laurens de germond qui est
cofondatrice de cruels avec moi qui a
imprimé sur de l'herbe sans aucun
produit en fait il s'agit ici dans ce
nom c'est avec des graines d'herbe une
plaque 2 0 qui est ensuite mise face à
un projecteur uv mais devant ce
projecteur uv et placer le négatif de la
photographie et le négatif va filtrer
les uv et l'herbe va recevoir plus ou
moins d'intensité du v selon le filtre
du négatif de la photographie et cette
intensité du v va donner une couleur
plus ou moins profondes à l'herbe est
ainsi l'image à s'imprimer sur le vivant
ce procédé écologique a ensuite été
utilisé pour des messages publicitaires
lors des jo de londres
pourquoi est-ce qu'un méthodes aussi
simple aussi artiste artisanale a pu
être expérimenté est déployée par un
artiste et ensuite devenir une référence
pour des productions mondial avec une
forte visibilité et une industrie aussi
puissante que celle de la publicité
c'est tout simplement parce que
l'artiste a plusieurs atouts dans sa
poche pour pouvoir influencer et
accompagner la première c'est que il a
droit à l'échec
il peut essayer des choses sans art
l'obligation de réussir il pourra
continuer après la deuxième c'est qu'il
n'est pas obligé d'avoir un modèle
économique dès le départ quand il
commence à travailler sur sa recherche
et que chaque oeuvre
en fait dans le parcours d'un artiste
contemporain mais que le témoignage
d'une étape dans une recherche plus
globale enfin il a aussi une image
sociale différente puisque il est perçu
comme étant un agent social neutre
contrairement aux politiques on
n'imagine pas qu'ils cherchent à se
faire élire contrairement à une
entreprise où elle marque
on n'a pas l'impression qu'il est là
pour faire de l'argent on a l'impression
qu'ils aient une forme de neutralité en
tant qu'agent sociale qui lui permet de
collaborer avec un ensemble d'acteurs
bien plus large que n'importe lequel des
autres et de créer du lien et donc de
laisser influencer tous
d'autre part il a le crédit de l'art
puisque on attribue aussi une certaine
valeur sociale et une valeur symbolique
allard ce qui est issu du monde de l'art
bénéficie de cette valorisation donc des
procédés parfois très simples qui serait
perçue négativement ou mal juger du
point de vue du corps social s'ils sont
portés par un artiste ou pas un ensemble
d'artistes donc à un mouvement
artistique
là ça prend une autre valeur symbolique
et ça peut se diffuser d'un corps social
donc l'artiste lui même est un
influenceur de conscience extrêmement
important et il peut aller plus loin
aussi
il ya une méthode très particulière qui
est issu de l'art contemporain qui
s'appelle la sculpture sociale le
premier théoricien de cette idée c'est
un joseph beuys qui a pour intérêt
d'être à la fois un artiste mais aussi
le co-fondateur du parti vert en
allemagne donc à la fois un engagé
politique et en même temps plasticien et
l'idée de sculpture sociale
c'est clairement de l' influence c'est
en fait une méthode qui permet sous
couvert de l'art mais qui peut être
utilisée également politique de
constituer un groupe social autour d'une
cause commune ou d'une forme commune
d'une action commune qui bénéficie de ce
cet attrait culturel et social
qu'apporte le dernier artistique pour
les mobiliser à faire quelque chose
ensemble est quelque chose qu il y a une
portée pour la cité ont porté pour
politique ici on peut prendre pour
exemple aimé belkin qui est une artiste
qui depuis 2005 a dédié toute sa
pratique artistique principal à une
cause unique
son objectif ultime est de faire
reconnaître le climat comme étant un
bien commun de l'humanité auprès de
l'unesco
pour ce faire et mène plusieurs actions
elle détourne principalement des
dispositifs existants sur l'image que
vous voyez par exemple elle détourne les
les affichages publicitaires et robin en
quatre par trois inconnus des
communicants et au lieu-dit promis d'y
diffuser des messages commerciaux de
promotion de marques ici elles diffusent
le message de son projet qui consiste à
constituer des collectifs citoyens
autour de la lutte contre le changement
climatique et d'effectuer un second
détournement qui consiste à détourner le
système financier autour du climat
en l'occurrence dans le cadre des
accords internationaux de lutte contre
le changement climatique
les entreprises de certains secteurs se
voit allouer des quotas d'émission de
co2 qu'ils doivent respecter si une
entreprise ne dépasse pas ses quotas son
surplus de quotas autorisés elle peut le
vendre sur le marché carbone et à
linverse une entreprise qui pas dépassé
son quota doit acheter sur le marché
carbone les quotas nécessaires pour
continuer sa production
mais c'est un marché à somme nulle
puisque le nombre de quotas final le bal
en circulation reste le même celui donné
au départ ce que eni belkin propose
c'est que les citoyens interviennent
dans ce marché se constitue un peu comme
dans le cadre d'un croc phoning
rassemble de l'argent et achète avec cet
argent des quotas co2 qu'ils ne sont pas
réattribué à une industrie qui du coup
sont des quotas de co2 qui ne seront pas
aimé c'est une façon de détourner le
système pour réduire la pollution
globale donc l'artiste a aussi cet
intérêt de pouvoir mobiliser les gens
autour d'une cause sans modèle
économique sans autre intérêt que la
cause elle même est de mobiliser très
largement au delà des frontières ou du
système est d'être une forme de hackers
du système et c'est en cela aussi que
non seulement ils accompagnent
conscience mais aussi l'action et c'est
là où il devient un agent extrêmement
efficace d' influence en l'occurrence
pour la cause écologique
ce n'est pas tout puisque l'artiste peut
aller bien plus loin et c'est là toute
la différence
mais aussi tout l'enjeu aujourd'hui on a
développé un imaginaire extrêmement
détaillées et diversifiée sur un futur
de catastrophe un futur où la crise
écologique et sociale globale mènerait à
une collab son logis de notre
civilisation
c'est hélas un scénario probable mais
plus on a imaginé ce thème
rios plus elle risque de devenir réel et
donc la butte passe aussi par un
imaginaire il faut développer un
imaginaire contraire un imaginaire dans
lequel la transition écologique et
solidaire serait une réussite
on n'a pas développé cet imaginaire et
c'est le travail des artistes
en réalité à chaque fois qu'on a demandé
au corps social de faire un effort on a
réussi à obtenir cet effort parce que on
lui a développé un imaginaire d'un an
après où ça se passait bien
par exemple le communisme avait l'idée
des lendemains qui chantent la
révolution les efforts les dangers que
la population allait accepter étaient
récompensés infiné par ces lendemains
qui chantent
c'est un peu déchanté hélas mais c'est
cet imaginaire qui a appuyé la
motivation et la mobilisation de chacun
d'eux mêmes
imaginez au moment de la révolution
industrielle des gens qui ont quitté
leurs campagnes un certain confort
devise avait de l'espace y avait une
autosuffisance alimentaire et un certain
niveau de confort qu'ils ont abandonnée
pour partir dans des banlieues ou dans
des villes travailler dans des usines
dans des conditions de travail
incomparablement plus difficile d
concision de vie incomparablement plus
insalubres mais tout cela parce qu'ils
étaient motivés par la promesse du
positivisme la promesse du progrès la
promesse de l'accès à plus de services à
de l'éducation à une meilleure vie pour
leurs enfants
en réalité il n'ya que en proposant au
groupe un imaginaire d'un u positif
qu'on obtient leur engagement et leurs
efforts ainsi sur la lutte contre le
changement climatique et les onze élèves
d'université pour la réussite de la
transition écologique et solidaire
on a crucialement besoin de diffuser un
imaginaire positif de la transition un
imaginaire où on imagine la vie
quotidienne qu'on pourrait avoir quand
ça se passe bien et c'est là où les
artistes doivent intervenir de toutes
les disciplines que ce soit en arts
plastiques pour un imaginaire visuel
mais surtout aussi les médias les plus
puissants auprès du grand public à
savoir les séries les films la
littérature le spectacle vivant tous
peuvent prendre contribution à cet
imaginaire et il ya très peu d'exemples
à date
donc c'est un vrai sujet sur lequel on
doit
c'est le cas ici par exemple de suzanne
de ski qui développe un imaginaire très
bucolique très simple très coloré de ce
que serait la vita demain ou le monde de
demain
extrêmement jolie et joyeux enfin pour
finir le plus intéressant avec cette
démarche en utilisant l'art c'est
surtout qu'elle n'est pas identifié non
plus comme étant géographiquement
limitée ou culturellement limité l'art
contemporain sont intéressés qu'il a une
scène mondialisé et surtout dernier
point et c'est là où ça devient vraiment
influent on pourrait se dire après ce
que j'ai dit que le plus intéressant on
serait de travailler sur les scénarios
des seuils ou des films puisque c'est là
où une influence le plus grand nombre de
personnes mais l'art contrairement à
quelque chose d'un peu à part c'est que
c'est aussi un marché essaie des
collectionneurs
les collectionneurs sont les personnes
les plus fortunées or ces personnes les
plus fortunées sur celles qui polluent
le plus
dans la consommation individuelle du
fait de leur monnaie mais c'est aussi
celle qui sont souvent les capitaines
d'industrie et qui du coup prescrivent
ce qui va être offert au grand public et
les facteurs de pollution de la
consommation de chacun c'est pourquoi
l'art contemporain est un vecteur
d'influencé et de prise de conscience à
la fois universelle et en même temps
auprès du public ciblé le plus
précisément qui a le plus d'impact
merci beaucoup